every gameplay video of Metal Gear Solid
5 the phantom plane looks awesome the
clips they just scream out play this
bucket and it's gonna have all the
things that make open-world dynamic
sandbox of games just completely amazing
but there's also some trailers which
have all these characters and moments
and bleeding and it leaves me so far
behind in the dust that I just write off
the phantom pain as impenetrable without
any real knowledge of the Metal Gear
lore I really hope I could keep up
it wasn't sure so I had a lot of our
in-house Metal Gear fans send me their
thoughts to be honest the whole Metal
Gear storyline is a bit crazy it's it's
really really stupid sometimes sometimes
it's really interesting but you know you
don't need to know about the storyline
to enjoy the phantom things the really
really cool thing about the phantom pain
is its open-world stealth which is
actually kind of a new thing it's not
really been done before you could you
know be about a mile away from the base
and you could find a high vantage point
and you could get your binoculars out
and you could just scope out the whole
place and the amazing thing is you can
find the weak spots so you can find ways
of getting into the base you can find
ways of sneaking through and that's
actually really cool just looking our
base and thinking I know exactly how I'm
gonna infiltrate that you're dropped in
this massive open map of Afghanistan and
you're always at risk of being spotted
there are guards who go inside vehicles
and just drive around the entire area
there are helicopters that sometimes fly
but passed on on your way to a base you
can you can accidentally stumble into an
outpost where yo someone just spots you
and as soon as they spot you they call
for reinforcements and all of a sudden
just a tiny mistake where where someone
spots you in the distance
can escalate into this massive all-out
war and it's really cool Andy okay so an
employee thing the story of phantom pain
if you're scared of getting into the
phantom pain because the story you've
heard it's like really crazy and batshit
insane that's correct
- you know point I mean I've played old
Metal Gear games and I played three or
four hours of phantom pain and even
knowing having all that knowledge that I
had I was still just yelling at the TV
being like what the [ __ ] is going on the
entire time so if you're worried about
just not getting it at all story-wise I
wouldn't worry too much about it it
doesn't playing the game it's not really
necessary for you I played the rest of
the series but I do really recommend
that if you are thinking of playing
phantom pain you start playing Ground
zeroes now cuz it's definitely worth
having the control scheme is the same
and it's definitely worth having the
grand jurors muscle memory in terms of
moving snake around and knowing all the
different things you can do just as
snake because once you get into phantom
pain the narrative throws snake just
directly it's obsessed open-world
mission and it's like just go you're on
your own just go for it
how many people were giving grounds
there's a lot of [ __ ] for being just you
know one small map and a couple of hours
of gameplay but there was so much stuff
you can do in that small playground so
definitely do that
as a finally serious I could go on for
days about all the amazing things that
Metal Gear Solid 5 looks like it's gonna
have and make it worth playing the
open-ended stealth the refined combat
the crazy boss fights but honestly I
think the thing that I love about the
series and what I'm most looking forward
to in the phantom pain is seeing how
Kojima subvert our expectations every
single entry in this area so far has
done something weird to mess with
players maybe a solid had a malnourished
psychokinesis practitioner basically
treated you to a quick magic show Metal
Gear Solid 2 had one of videogames most
legendary baton switches by making new
players riding instead of Solid Snake
Nagas like three had you walk through a
nightmare swamp filled with the ghosts
of enemies you'd kill up until that
point and then aside for Shadow Moses
was an unexpected moment that was so
powerful I'd literally had to put the
controller down and catch my breath so
come on the saying is I can't tell you
what's gonna happen in my life I've in
fact no one can
because Kojima is a master of coming up
with wacky and weird things just
surprise into Laos either way you can
bet that the quirky aspects of that game
are gonna dominate social networks and
news headlines and the conversation for
a really really long time and you should
be bar that conversation you're seeing
it in game and experiencing it is gonna
be something that sticks with you for a
really long time and I imagine there's
gonna be a lot of things we all get the
vibe that I'll still be talking about
years in the future
when Tamar said I don't want to miss out
on the conversation around the phantom
pain plus it sounds like it's going to
be a really amazing sandbox stealth game
thanks to my fellow games butters for
sending me their voice memos and
definitely stay tuned to game spot for
more coverage of the phantom pain as
well as a full review
you